turkey's currency the lira has tumbled
to an all-time low against the u.s
dollar one day after turkey's president
cited muslim teachings to justify his
decision not to raise interest rates to
stabilize the currency while the weak
lira is driving prices ever higher many
people in turkey are struggling to buy
food and other essentials the steep
devaluation also has seen foreign invest
visitors rather mostly from greece and
bulgaria crossing into turkey to take
advantage of their newfound purchasing
power
all right let's get you more dw
correspondent dorian jones is standing
by in istanbul what does this mean for
the people in turkey
well it means suffering turkish people
are facing a tsunami of price increases
today saw petrol prices going up uh
dairy products have gone up over 50
percent in the last few weeks
rents are also soaring as landlords try
to peg
the rent rent rises to the
the rising dollar on top of that there's
expectation of heating bills will be
soaring as well first winter snows are
now hitting turkey that's because turkey
imports over 90 percent of its energy
and for turkish businesses the story is
also bleak they are warning that they're
fearing that people will no longer be
paying their bills so they are holding
off paying their invoices and on top of
that they are soaring a raw material
prices and a heating cost and even
turkey's exporters who have done
tremendously well out of the collapse in
the currency they are warning that this
uncertainty and chaos is leading them
not to expand their production because
they don't know what's going to happen
next and that will be a dash of
president erdogan who is pinning this
collapse in the currency to boost the
country's economy
well talk to us a little bit about there
in terms of his popularity how do people
view president erdogan's role in the
lira crisis
well turkish economy has been struggling
all year and that has hit president
erdogan's ratings and his ruling aka
party but this latest collapse in the
last few weeks of the currency which has
seen it collapse over 35 percent in 30
days has seen his ratings now reach rock
bottom they are record lows people of
impulse say 55 do not want to see him as
president as opposed to 35 who do and
his own party itself is also at record
lows even though it's still the largest
party but the main opposition parties
are ahead as a coalition so erdogan is
in a very deep uh predicament here and
it's very unclear how this will play out
for the president as all the expectation
is that the situation will continue to
worsen with president erdogan ruling no
step back from his very controversial
policy of cutting interest rates with
inflation soaring
so if the president continues to dig in
what option does president erdogan have
to stabilize the currency
well if president erdogan does reverse
his policy uh if he uh introduces a
major hike in interest rates people are
talking about possibly a 15 even 20
increase in interest rates that
stabilize the uh the turkish lira with
inflation
while it's widely expected to be
reaching 30 possibly 40 percent in the
coming weeks and if he was to uh
establish a an independent central bank
chief the wife expectation the countries
the erdogan runs the central bank not
the central bank himself if he was going
to return autonomy and independence then
the lira would stabilize but that would
be very painful for the turkish economy
and president erdogan has ruled that out
over the weekend saying that the cut uh
in interest rates is part of his muslim
belief according to the quran interest
rates are forbidden so i think all eyes
are now looking at prison erdogan's
parliamentary deputies there's growing
pressure on them to defect in large
numbers to which would lead them to an
early election and if you speak to
growing numbers of business leaders and
much of the country the only way out of
this crisis ac is an early election dw
correspondent dorian jones reporting
from istanbul he's been talking to us
about the dramatic devaluation of the
lira thank you
you